[Applause]
yeah this is pedestrian Casey
five years ago you bet me that he could
never be pranked a year later a plan for
the slowest burn prank of all time for
the god damn is taking me to Muizenberg
to go surfing and it's shot that word
that he just uses sharky sharky as in
like lots of sharks big great white
sharks I thought Dan was messing with me
I hoped Dan was messing with me now that
he was we going to shark infested bay
and our weight suits are black and we're
gonna look like seals which in turns
kind of makes us shark bait three words
B shark wise I always thought you just
Whitney that he just showed me that teal
point shark attack it really does happen
it happens and properly happens tell
them that she talked to sharks has what
I'm told you there's no sharks around
where seals are very safe no promise
we're gonna swim with the seals I'm here
to look after you as I said you know not
gonna put you in danger
yeah you see the seals down here what's
up I got you a prison for all of your
hard work and dedication oh man thanks
Jer I put Georgie Franny in Candice's
actual handprint Sunday yeah and I've
decided that I'm gonna take on the role
as being your Turkish your personal to
that client coach you can call me coach
all right coach it was at this moment I
knew he was ready okay so the last few
bits to organize would be the shark
I've been in here before
Oh Yosh if you don't know him irony this
is Paul the gnarliest most hardcore
person I've ever met Paul is one a
mutual friend of both KCI myself to a
navy clearance diver and three a shark
attack victims and Russell Baba a shark
attack survivor I'm just gonna cut to
some footage of the event it's not
gruesome or gory
[Music]
okay and I mean talking about recreating
the true authentic experience there's no
one else that would really know what
it's like to be in that position it is
one of the most awe-inspiring terrors
that you can have it's that sense of
zero control unknown it's an area the
ward absolutely if do you want the Finn
to just pop up and instantly scare the
[ __ ] out of him fear what do you want to
do you want me to like swim it so that
comes slowly up like that towards him we
should try and grab my knees leads I can
do that Joonas we see any form of
failure I just [ __ ] dot I'll try and
follow buses okay
[Music]
this is gonna be good yeah are you ready
for your first proper surf lesson okay
perfect so you know these okay this is
it
Casey believes I'm going to be taking
him and his good friend Roman for a surf
lesson at a nearby beach but meanwhile
Paul and some other videographers are
going to be setting up on the beach and
hiding in the bushes and Paul's gonna
swim around from a nearby bay calm down
and waits underwater until the time is
right we all sitting on the back line
and then pop out I really really hope
this works
yeah let's go surfing let's go are you
ready
[Music]
just this case he started spotting
something from far away the police that
were called on us created a great
division here where I'm coming from
all right with these eyes now facing the
shoreline I just had a wait for the fund
to be close enough to give him the
fright of his life behind you
okay I'm fine breathe oh my god it's a
prank it was a prank it was a prank it's
a joke
it's a joint that's Paul he's coming out
now come on
and that's JT and there's gaps and Jonah
and everybody you got pranked
I hate prank videos I know you've never
been pranked
[Music]
I pissed my work never serving with you
again you are fired at surf coach Yummie
$10 brought for the bet you bet me that
you can even be prat very so friends
yeah is this what you wanted to film me
for to get confirmation oh of course it
was very well done and I appreciated the
sheer amount of execution thank you for
watching subscribe I'll see you next
week
you